from our favorite westerns to our
favorite baseball films and more kevin
kosner has starred on screen for decades
now but how did he become the hollywood
star he is today what led up to his big
oscar win keep watching to find out
kevin kosner attended several different
schools as a teenager and as a result he
always felt like a bit of an outcast
repeatedly forced to start over with a
new set of teachers and peers he
struggled to find his social circle and
identify his own strengths kosner told
rolling stone along the way i kind of
lost what my own real identity was like
well who am i just some guy who goes to
a new school and god wants to just have
a couple of friends but growing up he
always had a strong interest in the arts
his parents were rather strict so he did
his best to stay out of trouble and he
excelled at a few different hobbies
kosner enjoyed writing poetry in his
spare time he also sang in a baptist
choir
while some actors knew that they wanted
to be in front of the camera at a young
age kosner didn't have that clear vision
of his future just yet however he
definitely had a creative streak that
was always evident
growing up kevin kosner always did have
a love for the movies granted he had no
idea that he would be starring in films
of his own one day but he often found
himself getting lost in the great ones
there were a few movies that made a
particularly profound impact on it
kosner has stated that the classic film
how the west was one formed his
childhood he also sought out other
western films he loved red river and the
searchers both of which are considered
two of john wayne's best films he always
felt a connection to this time period in
american history and it influenced his
choice of acting roles as his career got
off the ground this includes the types
of projects he was inclined to select as
he rose in hollywood and he would
acquire the type of cloud it takes to
make major movies happen through sheer
force of will
after graduating from high school kosner
began studying business at california
state university fullerton but as the
years went on he still felt like he
wasn't connecting with the people around
him and he eventually realized that
business wasn't his true calling after
all kosner recalled while speaking with
rolling stone as i approached my senior
year i had a real talk with myself about
what i wanted to do and whether i just
wanted to please other people and it was
at that moment that i actually said to
myself i'm interested in storytelling
looking back kosner described the way
the moment he realized he wanted to be
an artist regardless of what anyone else
thought was very liberating he continued
if you want to look at a high point in
my life it wasn't a movie it was that
internal talk i had with myself where i
said i am going to go where my heart
wants to go
although kevin kosner eventually decided
what path he wanted to take he still
felt that he needed some encouragement
after all pursuing an acting career is a
major risk and he worried about whether
or not he really had what it took to
succeed in hollywood but a chance
encounter with academy award-winning
actor richard burton gave cosner the
confidence he needed to go after his
dreams kosner and his wife were catching
a flight home on their way back from
their honeymoon when the newlyweds
noticed that burton was also seated on
their plane kosner was nervous to
approach the actor to ask for his advice
but he decided to go for it anyway and
he was relieved when burton was
supportive of kosner's ambitions kosner
told yahoo entertainment i desperately
wanted to talk to him the conversation
never really expanded other than there
was a gentleness and a kindness and
looking at me saying i think you should
try this this was just what kosner
needed to hear and after receiving this
bit of affirmation he finally felt
confident that he could make a living as
an actor
like many aspiring actors kevin kosner
wasn't exactly rolling in dough during
the early days of his career when he had
that pivotal conversation on the plane
with richard burton he was working in
marketing as he invested more and more
time into his acting career he took on
odd jobs to pay the bills while going on
auditions he had absolutely no
connections in the entertainment
industry so he genuinely started from
the bottom he had to learn how to
navigate the business all on his own
kosner was getting his career off the
ground before everyone had a cell phone
in their pocket and he admitted that he
had a very unusual living arrangement
and a very unique way of learning
whether or not he'd landed a gig kosner
said in an interview with the
independent when i decided that i was
going to be an actor no one gave me a
chance i certainly didn't know how it
worked i used to drive my truck in every
day to la brea and sunset and park by a
phone booth and just go to sleep in my
truck because i didn't know what else to
do
when the good lord willing
things will work out
eventually kevin kosner began landing
some small roles in movies he
technically made his professional acting
debut in the indie film sizzle beach usa
also known as malibu hot summer he
played the owner of a horse stable in
malibu who has a fling with a summer
tourist but the film wasn't released
until well after it was initially shot
therefore his bit part as a frat boy in
night shift could probably count as his
first on-screen appearance of course his
unnamed character doesn't exactly play a
huge role in the film but at this stage
of kosner's career he was grateful for
any opportunity to get in front of the
camera in 1982 kosner also made a brief
uncredited appearance in the film
francis sure he wasn't a household name
just yet but in the early 1980s kosner
was finally starting to get his foot in
the door and make some connections these
minor roles weren't especially
impressive but he was making some
progress
in silverado kosner played jake an
exuberant gunslinger and one member of a
group of misfit cowboys who end up
chasing their fortunes to the town of
silverado however if they want to strike
it rich they'll have to settle their
scores with a corrupt rancher and the
local sheriff silverado is the kind of
western movie that kosner loved to watch
as a child and it earned positive
reviews from critics and brought kosner
more publicity in review for the moving
picture show critic joe laden wrote
kosner a relative newcomer gives an
ingratiating performance that should
mark him for bigger and better things
kosner's working relationship with
silverado's director lawrence kasdan who
also wrote the empire strikes back and
raiders of the lost ark opened up doors
for him in hollywood in fact 1985 turned
out to be a big year for kosner after
the release of silverado he went on to
appear in the film fandango and he was
also on an episode of steven spielberg's
tv series amazing stories
a couple of years after silverado's
release kosner took his career to new
heights with a starring role as elliott
ness and the gangster thriller the
untouchables kosner agreed to take on
the role of the real-life prohibition
agent because he was drawn to the
strength of the screenplay citing it as
one of screenwriter david mamet's best
scripts he was also offered the biggest
paycheck of his life as he was able to
negotiate with paramount for a 1 million
salary for the film the untouchables
co-starred the legendary sean connery
and robert de niro and kosner's
instincts about the adventurous crime
drama proved correct the film was
nominated for four academy awards and
critics noted his skillful performance a
critic for the orlando sentinel named
jay boyer wrote in a review the
untouchables could be the breakthrough
movie for kevin kosner a folksy gary
cooper-ish actor who holds center stage
as elliott ness
never stop fighting till the fight is
done
in 1987 kosner starred as navy
lieutenant tom farrell in the crime
drama no way out which finally
established him as a true leading man in
this neo-noir thriller farrell has an
affair with a young woman named susan
atwell played by sean young who later
turns up dead farrell knows that his
superior defense secretary david bryce
also had a fling with susan which
complicates the mystery farrell is put
in charge of figuring out who committed
the crime but as more clues are revealed
he worries that he might somehow be
implicated starring in no way out was a
landmark moment for cosner's career he
wasn't just the big name of the moment
he'd proven that he could command the
lead in a serious gripping film and he
was well on his way to becoming one of
hollywood's a-listers although the
untouchables was received well by
critics no way out earned even higher
praise particularly in regards to
cosner's role in fact roger ebert said
of his performance it's a lot more
interesting and complex than his work in
the untouchables of course while we'll
definitely defend cosner's performance
in the gangster flick there's no denying
the actor was improving with each film
early in his career kevin kosner had
already appeared in the baseball movie
chasing dreams but in the late 1980s his
starring roles in the successful films
bull durham and field of dreams created
an enduring association between the
actor and the sport of baseball later he
also took on roles as a baseball player
in two other films for the love of the
game and the upside of anger as you've
probably guessed cosner does have a
personal love for baseball and he's
always been a huge fan of the sport in
fact he owns a ranch in aspen where he
enjoys bringing his friends and family
together to play the national pastime
kosner told the denver post i built a
real baseball diamond there and i have a
lot of friends come out and play i have
friends connected to ncaa baseball teams
so they come on out to the field kosner
has shared that he enjoyed playing
baseball with his dad growing up and his
father definitely influenced his passion
for the sport
kevin kosner saw the most important
achievement of his career with dances
with wolves an epic western that he
directed and starred in in this 1990
drama kosner played union army
lieutenant john j dunbar who's sent to a
remote outpost of the american frontier
and begins living with a lakota tribe he
decides to leave his previous life
behind become a part of the tribe but
when other union soldiers arrive with
plans for their land he finds himself in
a dangerous position critics lauded the
film for revitalizing the western genre
without resorting to cliches brian d
johnson wrote in a review for maclean's
while violating almost every hollywood
taboo kosner has restored some of its
most cherished traditions he has created
an adventure with hot-blooded action
breathtaking scenery and a noble theme a
spectacle with the sort of widescreen
grandeur that has become almost extinct
funny enough kosner said that he
originally didn't want to be in the
director's chair but no one else seemed
to understand the script the way he did
kosner told the new york times i never
had a burning desire to direct but
everyone i showed the script to knew
what the film didn't need what should be
cut but i knew this was a three-hour
film dances with wolves ended up
solidifying kosner's career and earning
12 academy award nominations and seven
wins kosner was awarded best director
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you